I want you to remember what we proved
last time what do we prove last time
limit to three derivatives we said for
all of the young all of the basic trig
functions right the three basic ones and
really bit down to one basic one the
derivatives actually are very very
simple in fact these are really nice
symmetry to it so we started off with
sign that we felt as Trudy was her site
right so we then said okay obvious next
question how about her son now we found
it it didn't take you directly back it
took you to negative side right and then
the last one we used questions wrong we
found that she also came out quite nice
incidents in sense where right so that's
nice and later okay obviously even
though we're gonna get to a bit later
each of these statements which is a
derivative we give you a statement about
an interval my little get want to the
expression of later this week but I just
want to have these back in our minds I
guess as well following on from this not
that you necessarily need to ever
written down because I think the concept
now that was certainly way that
hopefully it doesn't require an action
but if I were to convert all of these
into chain right so if I had not just
sign X let's sign off some function
right what would happen there what would
happen to be different Ritchie what this
sucker what does changing tell me
you do the inside so you do the outside
right so the inside is camp so it's
derivative li BF - and then sign turns
into cosa so this is what chain rule
looks like beside okay and exactly the
same way what does chain rule look like
well cosine you go do the inside becomes
f - do the outside turns into - science
I'll put the minus way out the front
then you can turn sign like so therefore
just to complete it tan
f - and then of course the tan part of
it turns into sex crap when students
different [ __ ] these and get these
results common errors include writing
the F - and then doing SEC squared and
then thinking oh yeah I know exactly
what it looks like I'm forgetting
there's a whole extra function and then
I'm letting off the minus side or
reversing the mine side another common
error these are at least all these basic
results they're all on your reference
sheet
no excuses okay I do you think you
should be referring to that because you
guys wouldn't use them on what but
there's no reason to be on the same way
should just cheat this when I'm going
through my paper and double-checking
making sure I made most of the mistakes
and should just refer to this glance at
one more time so now I can differentiate
cheap functions hooray there are four
main applications of being able to do
this like this is a theory there are
four main areas that that's used it okay
what was the very first thing that we
started doing this very first kind of
problem we started solving when we first
started appreciating . my trig functions
just like follows what do we do with
them yeah oh we got two areas under
chairs we had to take awhile to get
there we had to go past differentiating
though we had to get to integration two
new areas on the contract so that isn't
applications but it's an application of
the other side of this if I remember
like yeah dream is our our gradient
right so the main thing we use them to
with at the beginning was to find
tangents involved because tangents and
normals are all about okay well you need
to know the gradient of something so
find what potential
Hey so that's the first place we're
going to begin that's the first kind of
question you'll encounter in 14h
anything goes on from that we're going
to have a look at a series of compound
functions by which I mean you've got
functions and they introduce a sine or
cosine interest as an example some
people get really upset by tree as an
example a classic one is a V X cos x now
you're actually going to encounter this
question in the exercise shortly I want
you to think about what this does a DX
if you just saw a to the X what's that
graph that's the exponential Bush of the
girls right so it's describing anything
that is growing and growing and growing
and it grows faster the bigger it is
okay now what difference does this make
what does this add into this now what's
happening is it's going up and down at
the same time it's growing and growing
and growing growing right so this what
we call it has this oscillating behavior
whereas this has this growth behavior
right so it's going up and down but it's
getting bigger and bigger and it's
stretching out okay so if you have what
we call you know a positive feedback
loop and something is getting bigger and
it's affecting itself again its
effective getting greater
okay this is the kind of thing you get
if you have a look at something like
this think about this for a second what
have I changed
instead of getting bigger and bigger and
bigger this is getting smaller and
smaller and smaller this is a situation
which we called epic right that you've
got something's went back and forth
damping right but the effect it getting
smaller than smaller than small so for
example if I'm every stringed instrument
every stringed instrument in the world
when you striking it it starts to
oscillate goes up and down up and down
but then if you just leave it just by
the nature of tension in the string and
air resistance it'll gradually slow down
until it stops and that's exactly what
this picture is doing yeah these are
compound functions but they involve the
trig functions in them to give that to
pop down to a note so in order to do
with them we needed all of these that's
a classic application um last two rates
of change we've looked at rate to change
before we're like okay something is
getting bigger or smaller something's
being poured in or something's being
drained out if you have something and
it's changing based on some kind of
angle okay so for example you've got a
arm you know say you've got a lighthouse
and it's shining a light on a certain
area okay well what's changing in that
situation is the lighthouse is changing
its angle okay there's a rate of change
associated with some kind of distance
out there that matches to that angle and
obviously trig is going to be involved
because angle is movable so anything
where there's a rate of change involving
something like that on a triangle that's
just getting bigger and bigger and
bigger things angle is getting large off
all of those require sea able to
differentiate these guys and find out
though where's the stationary point
where's all of the un-- for the next
thing which is the last kind where is
the maximum all of the minimum right for
example he's actually a classic question
let's take about my house example
suppose there was a lighthouse tank
right here okay
and it was shining a light at the walls
of this classroom okay you can imagine
if I show you right back there
all right the sides okay in other words
so the beam of light is a normal to the
wall okay and if it's just the normal
way what shape will be traced
it's just going to be a circle but if I
go to like say the corner okay you're
not going to get a circle if I shine at
the corner I know what's gonna happen to
the shape of the light here's the booth
right here's like Maya here's my light
source okay if I go directly across but
you guys can see this right if you start
to go this way
right your light beam is sort of doing
this it's stretching out okay so the
question is and this you don't need to
think about this is a an area problem
it's really just for that week because
that's a charity where's the maximum
width of the light where does that take
place because eventually you hit a wall
and then it starts to get smaller and
smaller and smaller what is the actual
width so this is a classic maximum from
this actually particularly very very
hard
there's just the first example I thought
because most so any place where you've
got angles and they're changing you'll
have a triangle or a cylinder or current
or waning anything like that and it's
getting bigger it's getting smaller and
just like we sold maximum of you for now
that you can differentiate these guys
you can find stationary points you can
determine their nature do everything you
could before we treat pumpkins enough
does that make sense